[Music]
[Applause]
Andrew Whitworth Amazon Prime Thursday
night football analyst Super Bowl champ
with the Rams and a four-time pro bowl
offensive lineman joining us on the
program courtesy of Mattel you got a
philosophy on rookie quarterbacks there
you know I think I agree with you it's
one of those things I think there's
really not a bad decision but you look
at recent history you know most guys
have waited have set out a little bit
sat from the sideline and watched some I
mean I understand with him you know they
feel like I don't know how competitive
they're going to be this year so why not
put him in there and just learn as we go
but I kind of agree like it'd be
interesting to see maybe keep him out
until he gets to that point in the
season and then play from there because
at least then you don't start off a
whole year 17 games of uh him having a
rough go of it because you're going to
have a learning process you're a Peyton
Manning talk about that you hear a lot
of guys you know that played early man
what a grind that was and the last thing
you want is him losing any confidence uh
at that position going into next season
what's it like when you get in the
Huddle and you realize that that
quarterback is just nervous as can be
you know I think for me I mean I I
started off with a veteran quarterback
and then later in my career Andy Dalton
came in as a rookie starting at the very
beginning himself AJ Green I had a bunch
of rookies in there Clint bowling AJ
Green Andy Dalton uh you know you look
around the hall you can tell you know I
think they they think sometimes that you
can't see it in their eyes
but uh you know when there's a little
shakiness going on and so I think just
settling those guys in and that's where
you know Quentin Nelson some of those
guys it's going to be useful man you're
gonna have to talk liking to him
continue to talk that confidence into
him because he's going to make great
plays and be on cloud nine and then he's
gonna make plays where he's going to
feel like man I don't know if I can do
this or not and he's going to need
veteran presence in that huddle to get
him going each and every week throughout
the plays and the Ebbs and flows of NFL
football
I know you're looking at the preseason
differently than you did when you were
playing but as an analyst what should we
take away from any performance in the
preseason good or bad
you know I can be cynical sometimes I
get too negative on the preseason there
is plays that matter uh it is good to
see some guys get out there and take
significant snaps you know obviously my
last five years are Sean I don't think I
touched the field in the preseason but
maybe once
um so I'm not a huge preseason fan I
think that sometimes especially with
Edge rushers uh Corners you know when
they're going against guys when you're
talking about man-to-man world living on
an island as tackles Corners you know
Edge rushers receivers the talent really
does matter who you're facing matters
and and so I think we can get a little
too excited sometimes just seeing a
great rush or a great play by tackle if
he's not playing somebody who's really
going to be out there on Sundays but you
know it's good to see them produce and
and the show production and show what
they're going to look like during the
season I think you can kind of find some
clips where you say all right this is
going to be a problem for this guy or
you know what that if he can get to this
during the season uh he's gonna have
success why does Sandy read play Patrick
Mahomes in the preseason
Andy Reed's old school look as much fun
as Andy Reid likes to have he's got one
of the toughest training camps you know
talking to Travis and Patrick this
summer I got to play golf in the
American Century you know what that's
the main thing they talk about is Andy
Reed doesn't play around he likes to get
after it he likes physical practices
they hit the ground in their practices
it's not you know tapping off all the
time there is some real tackling that
happens
um I think in his mind you have to do
some of that to really have your mindset
right for what the NFL season's like and
that's the way he's convinced it's done
and uh he's been pretty successful at it
well I know and other coaches emulate
that
I think sometimes you get into all the
sports science stuff that's part of this
new era of football and and you can
overthink every little moment and I
think some coaches it's all about how
healthy can we be week one you know do I
have every single guy that I want on the
roster week one ready to go and healthy
and that's the only thing they think
about and I don't know if you're really
ever in control of that I think
sometimes you think you are and you
think you can control it by keeping them
out of preseason games or limiting the
action but then at the end of the day
there's there's some kind of consequence
for that when you get into game one or
two because I know even for me not
playing in the preseason the nerves I
felt my first two games in the season
even as a 16 14 15 year vet
were a lot it was more more nerves than
I normally felt going into a football
game and so you just you haven't been
out there in the pads I'm lighting it up
the lights are on the people are
screaming and it's like there's a new
energy level so you got to be I think
able to handle that a little bit so it's
interesting that more coaches honestly
aren't on more on the side of Andy Reid
than the latter how often did you go to
the line of scrimmage and forget the
snap count
well I mean Dan I've never fall started
ever so I I don't know it's always been
somebody else's fault uh but you know
the quarterback's voice was weird or he
kind of stuttered it was always his
fault but I
forgot the snap count many a time I for
me really it became I started watching
the screens all these new stadiums you
can see the replays on the screens from
almost anywhere on the field so I would
be in the Huddle watching the play
before kind of dissecting myself all
right this was good that was bad you
know or whoa we didn't do this right and
kind of giving some feedback to guys
instead of really listening so a lot of
times I broke the Huddle in my left
guards actually were all young guys
obviously for my last seven eight years
I had them that was their job they
learned that in training camp your job
is to remind me to play
scrimmage because my old self has
probably gone 80d and forgot what we
were doing he's Andrew Whitworth he won
a Super Bowl with the Rams joining us on
behalf of Mattel these are the little
people thing that uh Mattel's doing
right yeah little people collector said
I got to do this for the Super Bowl uh
just for the game for the Eagles and
Chiefs it was amazing and such a success
that we've rolled it out to the regular
season here we are we got uh every all
32 teams are represented uh we're really
excited about it there's some really
cool people in there I mean all
different kind of figures that you're
going to get in the Super Bowl last year
you just had players from the game this
year you got your Joe burrow Josh Allens
Von Miller's people like that uh it's
gonna be really exciting I can't wait
for people to get a hold of these
because uh I know how special they are
personally
the difference of what you're eating now
as opposed to if you were playing this
season
which how different is your diet
you know uh you got to be on screen
ready right I mean the tv ads I don't
know how many pounds I could get ads
like 20 or 50 pounds maybe it depends
it's all about the next size for me so
uh yeah I definitely way better let's
put it that way I'm I can't have as many
you know what I've earned this meals I
have very little of those sitting around
talking about football instead of
playing it uh you don't earn your
calories Pride as well well what was
your max weight that you played at
oh early in my career probably 360 350
somewhere in there you know at the end
of the year I mean playing in Cincinnati
a little you know Skyline Chili's gold
star
uh you know it uh got wait got out of
hand a little bit later in the year
let's put it that way but that's big I
mean I see Joe Thomas now and if I said
to somebody you know what he used to do
they they might say if he played
football maybe he was a tight end or
something
yeah he's he's gotten it often and looks
great man it kind of you hear that all
the time the big guys get smaller the
small guys get bigger
he's definitely one of those guys that's
taking it all off I mean there's a
couple guys over time I think Alan
fanica and some of those and Matt Kirk
but it's uh you know what
I'm looking forward to eating good
staying healthy and keeping it moving
baby uh when's the last time you put on
your Super Bowl ring
I actually had a chance to go the USGA
Women's Amateur was here at uh U.S
women's amateurs here at Bel Air Country
Club a couple weeks ago and I got a
chance to go and do kind of the Tee Box
for their practice rounds and uh it was
a lot of fun did you kind of talk to all
the women and ladies that were teeing
off and get a chance to greet them and
welcome them to La so I wore the ring
just to kind of brag a little bit okay
put off they loved it it was the idea of
winning the amateur and I happened to
run into three LSU girls playing in the
Women's Amateur and we had a blast
talking about LSU they tried to get me
to play with them we had a good time
yeah but you've got your allegiance to
another school you can't play with LSU
can you what's that
that
you would be you'd be playing with them
you're okay with that yeah okay okay all
right LSU Tiger and your accent's not as
good as uh Brian Kelly's by the way well
he's got a much better Southern lingo
than I do I that was impressive I don't
know how he pulled that off I hope that
that was intentional I'll put it that
way uh but they got a good football team
this year I'm looking forward to it I'm
pretty excited I'm gonna get down to a
game 20-year anniversary of Our National
Championship in 2003 with Nick Saban so
I'm looking forward to getting down
there good to talk to you uh have fun
with Mattel thanks for joining us yeah I
appreciate it Dan Andrew Whitworth the
uh 2021 Walter Payton NFL Man of the
Year and uh four-time Pro Bowl offensive
lineman I had one of those moments where
I go did he play at Alabama and then all
of a sudden he goes no why would I have
a problem with LSU and I'm like okay Amy
Amy